[Música]
con nuestra segunda invitada del día
vamos a hablar de Colombia porque en
este país se aumentaron los cultivos de
plantas de coca en un 43% según el más
reciente informe de la Organización de
Naciones Unidas Colombia ya es el mayor
productor de cocaína del mundo y el año
pasado el área de cultivos de Coca se
expandió a 204.000 hectáreas la cifra
más alta Desde que la oficina de
Naciones Unidas contra la droga y el
delito comenzó a recopilar estos datos
en el año 2001 saludamos a Ana María
Rueda hayas investigadora senior de la
fundación ideas para la paz Ana María
Gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo América de Franz 24 y empecemos
con un panorama no
general porque se debe este aumento de
plantaciones de Coca el año pasado en
Colombia alcanzando niveles históricos
desde que se tiene el registro
bueno Muy buenos días a todos pues en
Colombia realmente venimos con una
tendencia al incremento que a pesar de
que en los últimos años durante la
administración del presidente Duque que
la administración anterior los últimos
tres años se mostraron descensos de
menos de 10 puntos porcentuales la
situación daba cuenta de que había una
atención muy alta al crecimiento porque
estábamos en un momento en el que por
una parte los grupos criminales o los
grupos armados
estaban de alguna manera después del
acuerdo de paz algunos reposicionándose
y otros contando espacios que ha dejado
las viejas FARC con las que se tuvo el
acuerdo de paz entonces había un mayor
control territorial nuevamente de grupos
armados y por lo tanto eso hace prever
de manera inmediata que hay un control
sobre el negocio la cocaína Por otra
parte el programa de desarrollo
alternativo el programa integral de
sustitución de cultivos ilícitos no
estaba funcionando muy bien Este es un
programa que surgió el acuerdo de paz un
programa muy ambicioso con unas ayudas
en el largo plazo a un número muy
importante de familias 100 involucradas
en el cultivo de hoja de coca y el
programa no iba muy bien tuvo demasiadas
problemas en su ejecución Y eso también
llevaba a pensar que podía haber
bastante re siembra de manera directa
por estas familias campesinas y
finalmente las herramientas con las que
el gobierno colombiano siempre ha
contado para poder reducir o eliminar
realmente los cultivos ilícitos son la
radicación forzada por la vida de la
expresión aérea o por la vía manual y
pues la radiación voluntaria que la ha
hecho Generalmente de forma
negociada con Los Campesinos la
radicación forzosa tuvo muchísimos
problemas en este último gobierno
primero porque las personas se podía
llevar a cabo la expresión fue
suspendida por la corte constitucional
en el año 2017 y el gobierno anterior
trató de revivirla y no pudo hacerlo
jurídicamente hablando y por otra parte
la radicación forzada se utilizó de
forma generalizada fueron más de 130.000
hectáreas en el año 2021
2020 exactamente y pues dio cuenta de la
INE de esta actividad es decir a pesar
de que se estaban erradicando digamos en
promedio 100 mil hectáreas al año el
siguiente año el nuevo informe de Coca
mostraba nuevamente más de 100.000
hectáreas en producción Entonces es una
estrategia que no funciona Esas son las
razones en términos generales por las
cuales no se podía prever ninguna
reducción y al contrario se podía prever
este tipo de crecimiento claro y digamos
eso bajo la administración del anterior
gobierno del presidente Iván Duque ahora
con la llegada del nuevo presidente
colombiano bueno nuevo recientemente
Pues en el cargo Gustavo Petro Pues esta
situación no podría mejorar digamos por
su plan evidentemente lo que llamó una
nueva política contra las drogas dijo
que esta persecución de la política
contra las drogas Pues estaba fracasada
y también sobre el proyecto de paz Total
que si no recuerdo mal ya él lo aprobó
El Congreso de la República de Colombia
creo que el día de ayer entonces claro
esto mejoraría digamos la situación de
seguridad
desarmaría muchas bandas y Bandas
armadas que estarían en esa en esa en
esas regiones de la plantación de coca y
pues todo podría indicar que si esto
pasa disminuiría entonces estos cultivos
de Coca como ve esta situación
Pues en términos teóricos sí de acuerdo
con los anuncios del presidente con con
la política de paz total uno podría
pensar que vamos en buen camino pero en
realidad los anuncios aparte de la paz
Total no han sido nada específicos en
relación con la disminución del cultivo
de Coca a pesar de que el del que el
discurso del presidente Petro es
bienvenido en términos generales por la
población colombiana y para las personas
que creemos que la política de drogas
debe cambiarse Y ser más efectiva no hay
realmente información sobre herramientas
específicas para la reducción de este
cultivo es decir el presidente Petro ha
hablado de la desmovilización por
llamarlo de alguna manera acogimiento lo
han llamado de las de las bandas
criminales Pero eso no no no no no es
segura que el cultivo de Coca se acabe
por lo menos disminuya porque realmente
acordémonos que tenemos la historia de
lo que pasó con las Farc las fac dejaron
muchos espacios que en los que ejercían
control territorial y el gobierno no
tuvo la capacidad de asumirlos de forma
rápida y por lo tanto fueron captados
por otras organizaciones y de hecho
nuevas organizaciones alrededor de este
proceso entonces Creo que todavía
estamos ante un riesgo de que eso vuelva
a pasar por lo menos hasta que no se
aclare un poco más Cómo se va a manejar
este asunto ahora en relación con la
disminución las estrategias directas
para disminución de los cultivos de Coca
no hay ningún en este momento
información Clara sobre Qué hacer con
las familias campesinas Nosotros sabemos
que el gobierno de Petro tiene una
política
de seguridad humana quiere decir que va
a trabajar para la protección de las
vidas de estas personas y eso nos hace
intuir que va a trabajar con las
personas para la reducción de los
cultivos en torno al mejoramiento de su
bienestar eso llevaría en el largo plazo
a la reducción de los cultivos de coca
en Colombia pero no vemos ninguna
propuesta en concreto para darle un
ejemplo el programa de sustitución de
cultivos ilícitos continúa de la misma
manera en este momento no tenemos ningún
tipo el camino el programa sigue
encaminado de la misma forma a pesar de
que no está funcionando muy bien
entonces por lo menos en materia de
hacer alternativo no hay nada sobre
radicación hemos tenido mensajes
confusos realmente que no se volvía
erradicar recientemente que continúa la
radicación forzosa pero con cuál
estrategia de qué forma se va a radicar
Con qué tipo de focalización es decir
realmente no hay información que a mí me
permita decir que vamos en un buen
camino hacia no la solución porque
sabemos que esto no es un problema de
soluciones un problema de reducción y de
mejoramiento de las condiciones de
vulnerabilidad de las familias de los
territorios colombianos no tengo
información para poderles ir a usted qué
opino que vamos por buen camino todavía
claro Ana María y también pensar en en
la seguridad económica de esta familia
porque para nadie es un secreto que no
es rentable para un campesino en este
momento en esa zona sembrar papa o
cualquier otro tipo de alimentos que la
coca que es lo que realmente le da el
dinero entonces evidentemente frente a
eso pues la familias tienen que
subsistir de una manera Entonces es como
un ciclo vicioso que como bien usted lo
dijo pues nunca nunca se va a acabar no
Y también si no tenemos una Claridad de
nuestros gobiernos de una política
efectiva no para ayudar a tratar a
disminuir y pues que no produzca tanta
cultivo de coca y también producción de
cocaína en el territorio colombiano como
estamos hablando en este momento pues
imposible hacerlo no también este
cultivo específicamente digamos está en
la zona fronterizas para para facilitar
esta exportación como el gobierno
colombiano puede trabajar también con
los gobiernos vecinos para disminuir
esta esta producción de coca
a ver el gobierno colombiano siempre ha
trabajado muy fuertemente con los
vecinos pues ustedes que todos sabemos
que tiene una cooperación bien
importante con el gobierno de Estados
Unidos y en las cifras Incluso el mismo
informe ustedes pueden ver como el
número de incautaciones en Colombia es
gigantescos el país que más incauta en
el mundo Eso quiere decir que la lucha
contra el tráfico en términos de la
cantidad de cocaína que están
Todo el tiempo cogiendo en las tanto en
las fronteras como en los mares como en
los ríos es gigantesca Entonces yo creo
que el esfuerzo de Colombia es titánico
en ese sentido nunca ha dejado de serlo
lo que eso prueba es que los esfuerzos
por muy grandes que se hagan frente al
mercado ilegal de drogas sobre
narcotráfico no van a generar una
eliminación del problema lo que van a
ganar es una reducción del problema
Entonces si la pregunta fuera Cómo hacer
yo creo que ya están haciendo lo que hay
que hacer es posible que se requiera
mayor comparación con otros por países
porque el tráfico también va generando
unos cambios de dinámicas en relación
con los países de Centroamérica y los de
África para poder llegar a mercados de
Europa y de Estados Unidos pero yo creo
que en términos de cooperación con esa
con ese propósito se está haciendo muy
bien lo que creo que no funciona es se
está haciendo muy bien en términos de
los esfuerzos posibles lo que creo que
no funciona es que ya todos sabemos y
tal vez Todos hemos entendido que la
solución no está ahí o sea el esfuerzo
interruptivo tiene que continuar
haciéndose porque eso de alguna manera
genera desincentivos o reduce un poco la
producción de cocaína no cuando usted
por ejemplo desmantela un laboratorio un
cristalizador de coca que es donde se
hacen grandes cantidades de cocaína Pues
usted le da un golpe económico a una
organización pero es importante entender
que la organización rápidamente vuelve a
armar el cristalizadero sienten las
pérdidas para una organización en un
negocio que tiene tantísima rentabilidad
pues no genera un desincentivo real por
ahí no es la cosa eso hay que seguirlo
haciendo Porque todos tenemos la
obligación a nivel global de que llegue
menos cocaína a los mercados a todos
porque Colombia también se consume
cocaína no olvidemos eso estamos
consumiendo todo
pero en términos de la producción de
cocaína y del cultivo de Coca hay mucho
que hacer en términos de desarrollo
social y económico y a pesar de que ahí
se ha hecho mucho en Colombia también
con la cooperación de otros países
Generalmente no se ha hecho
suficientemente bien y de manera
continua Entonces si lográramos un mayor
desarrollo económico y social lograremos
una reducción gradual es decir el
problema está en exigirle a Colombia que
reduzca la producción de cocaína en un
año eso es imposible y le genera una
presión política que hace imposible un
proceso de desarrollo económico
aceptable